Our last question was about cookies.
This person had an interesting point about whether or not storing the session info
in the database was actually better or not.
In the general case, the answer is no.
If you're storing sessions in the database, that probably means you're hitting
the database on every page request.
Because sessions kind of by definition only last the session.
If it's not permanent data, if it's just are you logged in,
obviously you have to store are you logged in in a a cookie,
because that's how you are logged in.
Things like user preferences--my feeling is if the user is anonymous
and you allow anonymous users to have preferences and a little bit of state,
trying to store it in the cookie first.
Because you don't want anonymous users to hit your database.
Say your website gets popular and they write about it in the New York times or something,
and you get thousands and thousands of users before you were prepared.
If all of a sudden you've got a thousand people--I shouldn't say a thousand--
thousands and thousands of people writing temporary stuff into your databast,
that's going to hurt.
Now, maybe registered users, of course, you store them in the database,
but I still try to store as much temporary stuff in cookies as possible,
because that's the key to is stateless, getting the database out of the request,
hiding your database reads behind a cache,
hiding your database writes behind a queue,
which is something we really only talked about in unit 7.
That's the key to scaling, storing temporary data in cookies, which are designed for that purpose,
is a very important part of that.
Okay, I think that's about it.
Yes, I know we said good bye a couple of times. Now this one is for real.
First, Shawn, I'd like to thank you. This course wouldn't have happened without you.
Thank you, and thank you. You did an excellent job.
I know you kept apologizing that this is your first time teaching,
but I think all of our students will agree you did a great job doing it.
Thank you. It's been a lot of fun and a really cool experience.
I'm still hanging out in the IRC. There's still a group of people who do that.
Come join us if you want to talk about web apps or whatever.
Shawn I think is TAing a bunch of stuff.
The forums for 253 will still be around for ever, basically.
There are a lot of great students, your co-students, in the forums still helping out.
and a lot of people have posted a lot of great projects that they've done
in addition or just a completely different projects after what they learned in this course.
So congratulations to you guys.
Good luck out there and drop me a note, drop Shawn a note if you have any trouble
or want to share what you're working on. That'd be really cool.
Thanks, Shawn. Thank you guys. We'll see you around. >>Yeah. See ya.